more democratic presidential candidates
what Congress to start an impeachment
probe of President Trump after special
counsel Robert Miller's first comments
on his investigation Muller said
yesterday he could not exonerate the
president and explain why he could not
go any further under long-standing
department policy any president
president cannot be charged with a
federal crime while he is in office that
is unconstitutional the opinion says
that the Constitution requires a process
other than the criminal justice system
to formally accuse a sitting president
of wrongdoing
some Democrats claimed that statement
points the way to impeachment the
president tweeted this morning Robert
Muller would have brought charges if he
had anything but there were no charges
to bring chief Washington correspondent
major Garrett joins us now with more
major robert muller chooses his words
very carefully
what word stood out to you what messages
were embedded in those remarks well I
don't really think this is a process by
which you have to read between the lines
it was almost a Jeopardy question the
way Robert Muller put it yesterday
there is a process other than the
criminal justice system to charge a
sitting president what's the answer the
answer is impeachment I mean essentially
that was the way Robert Muller laid this
before Congress and it is now up to
House Democrats to take that implicit
and explicit message from the special
counsel citing the constitutional
prerogatives and the means by which to
take up this question is the behavior of
the sitting president acceptable under
the long-standing constitutional
definition high crimes and misdemeanors
to keep him in office or begin a process
of deciding whether or not charges
should be brought and the Senate to try
the president that's the essence of it
but something just happened this morning
that I think is very important in
addition to the tweet and Anthony just
read the president also tweeted this I
had nothing to do with Russia helping me
to get elected it was a crime that
didn't exist why is that important I
believe that is the very first time
president Trump on Twitter or anywhere
else has said
Russia helped to get him elected
previously everyone in the White House
said no we went to Wisconsin went to
Michigan went to Pennsylvania that's why
we got elected this is the sum total of
the Muller investigation creeping in not
only to the public consciousness but the
consciousness of the president and those
around him it's a major acknowledgment
indeed Robert Muller began his remarks
and ended his remarks by calling
attention to the fact that Russia had
interfere in the election and and
thought that should be important and on
the minds of all Americans the question
now with this acknowledgment in this
tweet from the president is the White
House doing something to ensure that the
2020 election will not be interfered
with in a similar fashion well Sarah
Sanders said yesterday on the White
House driveway the White House and the
administration have an all of government
approach to prevent any kind of meddling
in the 2020 election taking it more
seriously she said than the previous
administration meaning the Obama
administration that is a long-standing
talking point but it is important to
take the White House assessment of the
malla report at face value which is the
intrusion was real it is a threat in
2020 and that can no longer be contested
even though the president x gives it a
try major what do you think the
president's tweet this morning suggests
about how the White House feels about
impeachment well I think it you know it
feels the same way it always has about
impeachment number one that it's a
political gift for the White House
that's what they want to project they
want to continue to suggest to Democrats
it is folly for you to do this I'm not
saying that is true I'm saying the White
House wants to project that as a way to
discourage Democrats from going down
this road the White House believes House
Democrats are still reluctant to go
there but unless this process begins no
one will know for sure the White House
is trying to play a poker players game
bluffing their way through this idea
that if you go down the road from
impeachment you're going to guarantee
the president's re-election major before
you go how should we that people process
this if you listen to the White House
they're saying case closed if you listen
to the Democrats are saying this is
really impeachment referral what Robert
Miller was saying how should the public
process what they heard yesterday it can
be both gale because in the
criminal matter it is essentially case
closed no charges brought on a broader
conspiracy or obstruction but that's not
a standard necessarily for a president
the standard for a president is did you
do something in office that the Congress
decides is unbecoming and destructive of
the institution of the presidency itself
it's a separate non criminal question
which Congress led by the House
Democrats is going to have to confront
sooner rather than later all right major
Garrett Thank You major Jan Crawford
will sit down later today with Attorney
General William bar for an exclusive
interview you can see that tomorrow here
on CBS this morning